هناك مراكز ايواء تم فتحه في تلك الولايات
وفي عشر مدن تحديدا في المدارس وفي صلاه
الرياضيه
وفنادق ايضا استقبلت هؤلاء المنكوبين في
تلك المناطق ايضا هناك خيام لكن ميسون في
هذه الظروف الصعبه الجويه الصعبه هناك
تحديات تواجه السلطات ايضا تواجه
المنكوبين من المواطنين الاتراك هم بحاجه
ماسه وعاجله لمساعدات انسانيه وغذائيه
وايضا
لوسائل التدفئه في هذا الطقس العاصف وفي
العاصفه الثلجيه التي تتعمق يوما بعد يوم
وربما تستمر لايام طويله وبالتالي هذه
الثنائيه زلزال
والظروف الجويه شكل التحدي كبير
وصعبت من يعني جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه
وايضا من وضع المنكوبين الموجودين في تلك
المناطق يواجهون ظروفا جويه صعبه وبالتالي
بعض الناس يعني يفضلون العوده الى بيوتهم
حتى وان تعرضت لبعض
الاضرار
حتى يقيون انفسهم من هذه الظروف الجويه
القاسيه جدا ميسون لكن السلطات تشدد بان
ذلك خطر كبير على حياه المواطنين تحسبا
لاي هزات ارتداديه او موجات جديده من
الهزات الارضيه وحتى يتمكنوا ايضا من
العمل يعني
العمل في هذه الظروف القاسيه لانقاذ
العالقين تحت الانقاذ وما زالت العمليات
مستمره هناك
الجيش عمل على جسر جوي لنقل المصابين الى
ولايات اخرى وتقديم العلاجات اللازمه لهم
في المستشفيات الاخرى ايضا هناك محاوله
اجلاء وعمليات اجلاء لهؤلاء الملك
المنكوبين الى مناطق اخرى اكثر امانا